hi I'm John Green and two of my favorite
movies are Rushmore and Harvey for many
many years my boss at my first job kept
telling me to watch this movie Harvey
and I was like I don't watch movies in
black and white they're old and stupid
and boring and then I had this terrible
period of depression and I ended up
basically going into my boss's office
and saying I need to quit I need to go
home and he said just take a few weeks
and then and then we'll reassess and
right before I left he wrote me a note
that I still have and it says now more
than ever watch Harvey Harvey the movie
that is entirely dependent upon words
it's just really well-written like the
dialog and it is excellent nobody ever
brings anything small into a bar you
know and I am a word person when I'm
writing a novel I definitely try to live
in the world of words and figure out how
am I gonna use these scratches on a page
to make ideas that live in people's
minds Rushmore is an amazing movie about
the way that high school students kind
of take care of justice within their own
world jump little guy he's one of the
worst students we've got I feel like it
taught me a lot about how to tell on the
stories about high school Wes Anderson's
movies in particular have been very
helpful to me writing think the way that
he writes about young people in a
respectful and intellectually engaging
way and the way that he treats teenagers
with the same like thoughtfulness and
respect that he treats adult characters
is really inspirational to me I'm sorry
did someone say my name I don't use a
lot of movies in my mind when I write
but I definitely do
bring Rushmore into my brain when I'm
writing I'm John Green and I love movies